schools back in session river babes
welcome to the Sweetwater secrets
preview show for episode three ten
chapter 45 the stranger
I'm your host Liana Galera and because
the students of Riverdale are taking
their SATs in this next episode today
we're having a pop quiz do you think
Archie is really dead start commenting
your thoughts right now I cannot wait to
read them now also I'm pretty sure a lot
of you guys have been watching these
live sweet letter secrets preview shows
while you've been in school now I'm
gonna say is I'll totally write you a
note if your teacher catches you now
today I'm bringing you my three clues
about episode 310 and a new Shoni nugget
from Vanessa Morgan plus a special
Riverdale tell-all video about The
Gargoyle kings featuring Cole Sprouse
Lilly Reinhart and many more of your
faves but right now let's take a look at
all your kisses kisses comments and
theories from episode 309 chapter 44 no
exit now I've got to say that while I
was reading your thoughts on our last
week utter secrets after show I was
surprised to see that this was one of
our most divided comments section ever
and once again we had over a thousand
comments now we had people taking sides
and shipper Wars and plenty of
contradictory hisses and kisses but
we're gonna kick things off with
something that everyone agreed on Sophie
L wrote kisses to nana rose yes I agree
a thousand percent Sophie thank you for
starting us off with the one part of
episode 309 that we all loved sing Nana
Rosa's adorable face and spunky
personality Nana rose for president in
2020 next up we had a lot of
back-and-forth in the comments about
Veronica and Reggie's new romance now
colex Vina posted kisses to the edgy
that kiss was h.o.t and Buckhead bean
basically a hashtag married couple ah
yes well loved our brief Buckhead moment
but it seems like Tavia L doesn't not
like her Riverdale served with a side of
veggies because she commented hisses -
Reggie kissing his friend's ex after
everything our she has been through he
deserves better
River babes what do you think are you
intrigued by Veronica and Reggie as a
couple or are you a ride or dive Archie
fan and you know what I actually put
pull on et's community tab that over a
7,000 of you voted in 7,000 and here are
the results so far 49% of you voted I
loved hashtag veggie can't wait for more
28 percent voted max I'm not sure how I
feel about them yet and 23 percent voted
no way I miss Varkey now switching over
to another shift you all had a lot to
say about Shoni a lily Stuart wrote I
feel like Tony is just all about Cheryl
now like she used to be a badass serpent
but now she's just all about Cheryl
honestly girl I hate to say it but I
kind of feel the same meanwhile is Julia
Gomez said hisses to Jughead for giving
a second chance to things and not for
Cheryl and Tony but Louisa Marisa posted
his sister's Shoney's behavior why do
they think they can just get away with
stealing just because they're in the
mood for it
fangs deserved a second chance because
he did it for his mother honestly I'm
just peeved at things for telling Sweet
Pea about the pardon in the first place
keep your mouth shut and Ma's vita
selling money is peeved at well a lot
and commented I think people are taking
this whole Shoney's feeling thing way
too seriously the writers didn't have a
storyline and for some reason this was
all they saw for Shoni in the episode it
didn't make sense to me
like everything else in the episode fair
point and speaking of things not making
sense we're gonna wrap it up with this
gem of a comment from Frank Carlone who
wrote so let me get this straight
Cheryl and Tony burglarized the lodge's
penthouse apartment by crawling through
a window how did they get up there
levitation okay that episode mishap made
me laugh way to pay attention Frank but
now I want to shift our attention back
to the whole Shoni cat burglars thing
because half of you were horrified by
their behavior and the other half were
justifying it but just what did Vanessa
Morgan have to say about Shoney's new
illegal hobby take a look at what the
brunette beauty had to tell me stealing
from the rich to give to well us you're
so crazy I mean it's like Robin Hood
stealing from the rich and giving to the
poor I love that idea it's not
I think that's the right to do but I
think mean when it's stealing from Hiram
Lodge and then I think that's perfectly
okay with all the wrong that he's doing
and doesn't seem to be lacking and the
finances so I can see where you know
Shoni was coming from trying to help
people out even though maybe wasn't the
right thing to do but I think because of
who they're doing it to I'm a fan all
right our former serpent has spoken and
she's a fan of Shoney's bad girl
behavior but are you convinced it's okay
tell me right now in the comments and
we're gonna pause real quick because I'm
getting so many comments a lot of you
are saying Archie is not dead I don't
know a lot of folks are saying veggie is
endgame so keep sending your comments
you guys are flooding my iPad right now
and I'm loving it now looking ahead I'm
keeping my fingers crossed that episode
310 brings us a lot more plot
progression but by the looks of the
trailer it seems like emotions are at an
all-time high let's take a look at the
promo open your eyes think of it make no
mistake I will kill you I think it's
time
tell me where that money went they're
having a ceremony tomorrow night you'll
be there I think my favorite part of the
trailer was Fred threatening Hyrum and
then theme Riverdale's most despised
character bleeding on the ground now I
don't want to get too excited cuz we all
know that Riverdale loves a good dream
sequence and a fake-out death so at this
point I have no idea but I do know that
it's time for my three clues about
episode 310 chapter 45 the stranger so
here we go number one Riverdale's best
and brightest are ready for their SATs
but one student is noticeably absent
from the classroom number two when in
doubt throw a killer party and number
three the kiss of death may be coming to
Riverdale but one character receives
plenty of other smooches in the meantime
what do you think is going to happen in
episode 310 and what other questions do
you guys have for me start sending in
all of your thoughts because our
Sweetwater Q&A portion is coming in just
a few minutes but first I have a fun
little treat for you now when I was last
on the Riverdale set I sat down with a
handful of our favorite stars and asked
them to open up about this year's
mysterious Big Bad The Gargoyle King and
their honest reactions to our Twiggy
friend are just priceless
take a look come on
okay what do you really think of The
Gargoyle King I mean I think he's nice
he's a great guy I met him and his
family yeah he and his wife are doing
really well
yeah little Twiggy kids yeah they love
the little Twiggy kids yeah I think he's
creepy I think people make fun of him a
little bit cuz it's just like sticks I'm
like hey man if you saw that you're
telling me you wouldn't be scared do you
see that run yeah I mean I think it's
super creepy that would give me
nightmares if that showed up like in my
room or something like that I find it
really disturbing okay I remember the
first time I saw it I didn't even
realize they had it set up and it was
dark and everything and I had just
meandered over there and I saw this
massive thing and I screamed and it
freaked me out I ran back around the
other side and they were like listen I
was like and I just saw I don't know
what episode it is when Betty is
painting all the The Gargoyle
oh just like a parrot merci yeah no
that's that's too much for me soon
they'll join us oh thank you
I think he probably has quite a hard
time moving around in that outfit I've
watched some of the episodes and I there
were definitely times where I went how
did he get inside Betty's house and no
one hear it either he put the costume on
like they're really quick or he shuffled
through the small back door or window in
a bunch of twigs just duck in with his
little wings whatever they're impressive
further the gargoyle king is as stealthy
I would love to know who is underneath
that mask
I'd love to know may God have mercy on
our souls
that guy governor the king I hope you
guys loved that interview montage
because I had so much fun working with
my editor to create it for you guys also
one of you amazing river babes deemed me
on Instagram last week and told me that
you've been missing my super epic
gargoyle King impression so this one's
for you on that silly note let's take a
look at what you all have been
commenting me during this live sweet
letter preview there are so many
comments I'm so thrilled right now first
up we have eternal Nexus warrior said
all I can say is hisses to the
cliffhanger even though it's most likely
that Archie is alive the fact that they
ended it on a cliffhanger like that's
just annoying agree can't can't really
say anything more on that but I found
that annoying - another one of you guys
were commenting in last week Sweetwater
after-show saying that Archie looked so
cute at the end there and I was like he
almost died I don't know how cute that
is but all right Jenna says what we see
more bug-head because we hadn't seen
them in a while I cannot tell you too
much about what's coming up for bug head
right now it is a bit of a slow burn
because they've got a lot of other
things going on in these next couple of
weeks but I'm keeping my fingers crossed
that we get a little lovey moment
because it has been a while but I do
have some great things coming from Lilly
and Cole coming up for you guys to stay
tuned to Sweetwater secrets for that
Nikki says I think Veronica is picking
Reggie over Archie don't like it hmm
I am still I need to be convinced a
veggi I'm enjoying it I'm not quite sure
how I feel about it
I need more Harper says can you hint
about Shoney's next steps for
their relationship after being kicked
out of the Serpent's thank you here's
the thing about Shoni they have a bumpy
road ahead of them but I think that one
of the things that's so great about it
is that we're going to finally see a bit
of friction between them which means
we're gonna finally see them in a normal
healthy relationship so far it's been
all bubble gum and cherries and fun
times and stealing for them but I'm
excited to actually see them maybe have
a little bit of a friction moment amber
can you spill anything about the musical
episode for Heather's first off I'm
gonna say that you guys need to do your
homework River babes because if you have
not seen the movie heathers it is
amazing and I am so excited this is
going to be the musical episode this
year I might have something in the works
with the cast right now they're filming
it so stay tuned to Sweetwater for some
exclusive nuggets from the cast but I
think it's going to be a lot of fun good
things ahead Cathy do we get Fallis
anytime soon or have the writers
completely forgot about them oh my
goodness I'm miss phallus I know you all
do too we do have some very big things
in episode 310 for Alice and 4fp
not the two of them together but they do
have a very big twist coming in this
week's episode so I'll just leave it at
that so get excited Sprouse did it wrote
some people say there is more barchi in
this episode band bug head is that true
in terms of sharing scenes together I
would say there I can't say anything
right now
I'm not going to but I will say that if
you tune in to our suite other secrets
after show you will be getting an
interview from someone and you'll want
to tune into that I'm not saying
anything about barchi or bug head or
anything like that I'm just saying that
just tune into Sweetwater chastity for a
long time I assumed the farm had
something to do with the gargoyle king
but I feel like that is too predictable
if anything we know the show is anything
but that I don't know sometimes the show
is predictable I for a while there
thought that the farm had a big
connection to it because they're both
kind of two coltie situations
as of right now I'm not thinking that
we're gonna be getting that I do think
that hopefully we will be going to the
farm they are gonna be having a much
bigger prescient presence moving forward
and we will eventually be meeting Edgar
this year how do you guys think the
Edgar how do you envision him I envision
him as a very like kind looking man
who's got a lot of Secrets you tell me
how you've been picturing him constant
says do you think Cheryl and Toni
deserved to be kicked out of the
serpent's whoo so this what I'm about to
say is a little bit divisive do I think
Tony deserved to get kicked out of
serpents no do I think Cheryl deserved
to get kicked out of the serpents maybe
I feel like Cheryl was ever since the
beginning like granted Jughead was
working on a bunch of other different
things he was away a lot but as soon as
Cheryl got her jacket and got that it
was red and it was different she
couldn't help but be Cheryl and try and
take over and I feel like kind of a
Vanessa Morgan said in our last
Sweetwater Tony was just so excited to
be with Cheryl and have this great
girlfriend that she really just kind of
let Cheryl take the lead and she kind of
became more of a follower and I was
really bummed to see that so when it
really came down to Jughead having to
kick them out I do think that the fact
that Tony is a serpent by blood and is a
legacy in there she should have gotten
that pardon as well I feel like Cheryl
Prodigy what episodes are you most
looking forward to that's coming up I am
really excited for an upcoming noir
episode that I've heard a lot of been
about and that's the one where Kelly
Ripa will be joining as Hiram's
mistress from what Cole Sprouse has told
me it's a really cool vibe it's unlike
an episode that we've ever seen before
so I'm really into that and I trust
Cole's
taste in episodes because he really
seems to have his finger on the pulse of
what works with the show a lot of folks
are saying how much they love show knee
and phallus I'm here for it two of my
favorite couples I would like more from
that Maria what money is Betty talking
about in the promo you will find out but
let's just say Betty is on a mission to
get something back that belongs to her
let's see amber
oh no ice talk to Amber Cece is Shoni
gonna be back in the serpent's because
the last episode was not my favorite the
crime thing was just annoying I don't
know if they're gonna be back in the
serpent's actually I dunno but I can't
tell you that right now but if you keep
watching Sweetwater secrets we're going
to have an amazing exclusive on
something that I cannot really talk
about right now but it's going to be
epic and your first look is going to be
here and I'm so excited to show it to
you
Natalie says OMG alice is wearing makeup
yes she is wearing makeup in tonight's
episode and it is for a very important
job tune in later for the latest Mike
Matthews someone's coming back from the
dead tonight and two people might die
according to Roberto Roberto is getting
super heavy handed with those spoilers
there I'm not going to comment on that
but alright Roberto Emily says I think
that the farm is in the one who is in
the movie a dog's purpose that KJ office
started I didn't see that movie but
there you go
amber woo says I'm watching this during
school and it's totally freaking worth
it hi amber I'm so glad that you're
breaking the school rules right now to
watch Sweetwater secrets don't get
caught but I really do appreciate you
guys tuning in and having fun with me
these live episodes as you can tell
we've been doing them more frequently I
know that they happen when a lot of you
guys are in school so you're watching
them later but I do know that like I
appreciate you guys for tuning in Pratt
says will we see a Jones family reunion
and Allyson Gladys's fight oh I think
it's safe to say that Jones family
reunion is coming down the line they
wouldn't just have Gina Gershon be on
for one episode would they Keeley will
the Cooper's meet the Joneses soon that
would be amazing I not only do I want to
see Gladys meet Betty I really want
jellybean to meet Betty I've said this
before and I'll say it again those are
the two people that I need to see
interact together geraldi says can you
say anything about Betty sitting in
jugheads lap seen from the stills yes I
know what stills you're talking about we
use it to promote this live Sweetwater
preview right now as I'm going through
tonight's episode in my head I don't
remember
it there but they always send each
other's love you love each other
YouTube girl says is it true that
halfway this season The Gargoyle King is
revealed in the last half of the season
there's gonna be another mystery I can't
comment on that but I can't say that
roberto loves olga fix my hair right now
roberto loves sarees a little girl king
right yeah
roberto loves to break things down into
almost like chapters for Riverdale and I
feel like much like we had our black
hood chapter currently we're in The
Gargoyle King chapter I hope it ends
soon and then I think we're gonna be
moving into like the farm chapter I'm
getting deeper and deeper into that
myrrh Marielle says my history teacher
is yelling at me for watching this but
it's worth it for you Lea and Mary yo be
careful tell your history teacher I said
hi also pay attention in school there's
one line in tonight's episode I'm not
going to tell you who says it if
somebody says I'm in high school how am
I supposed to know that and I remember
sitting there and thinking back I'm like
high schoolers know everything you guys
are taught all of the things that later
in life everybody else forgets so I
personally think that high schoolers are
some of the smartest people out there
because they have to remember all the
things like math keep it up guys study
math um the barchi fans are going cray I
didn't say that you would be excited
barchi fans I'm just chill let's see
we've got a couple a little bit more
time let's see Kathy did we get more
Fallas any time soon like I said I hope
so
I you know Shawna shouldn't steal those
reasons shouldn't steal with those
reasons
yes Hyrum is awful and doesn't deserve
the money he has but Cheryl and Tony are
stealing for themselves even though they
have money and a home I know all the
Shoni stealing things was a lot but I
feel like we can all let it go at this
point
Maddy says I think that Fred will go to
Archie who is alive then make him return
to Riverdale where everyone finds out
what happened to him and is really upset
I will say they're spreading the episode
he's the best I love Fred I I want more
Fred if if there was a whole episode it
was just Fred and Nana rose and phallus
all just all the adults but no Hyrum and
no Penelope blossom or Claudius or any
of the it's just the good Hyrum there's
a good good set of parents all right
guys I'm gonna take three more right now
let's go away way way back Pratt says
well Betty help the sisters have quite
mercy kids out of the farm will we see
the farm ever I will say this now if we
do not see the farm and it is not an
actual form I'm gonna be so upset we've
heard about this mysterious farm since
season one of Riverdale it's time take
me to the farm I hope there's cows and
then Sofia says I'm so nervous for this
episode Sofia that's a good feeling to
have be nervous for this episode a lot
happens in it a lot
we're gonna have so much to discuss on
the after show just get excited and then
dawn says what did FP mean when he said
he wanted serpents to become players not
pawns just that he wanted them to be a
more active aggressive gang they used to
run the south side I don't really know
what the Serpent's have become now but I
agree with anything FP says I want them
to become badasses again truthfully two
more kyla will there be any more
intimate bug-head scenes not that I've
seen but hey I can't tell you how much
I've seen Holly can you reveal anything
about peaches and cream
yes peaches and cream is going to be a
new character that we will be meeting
coming up on Riverdale I've only heard a
little bit about her from what I've
heard she's really fun she will be in
the musical episode and she will also be
taking part in something else that I
hinted at earlier that I'm so excited
for you guys to talk about later
it's very cryptic it'll make sense in a
couple episodes but I'm so excited to
show you what I have and I think we're
gonna end it there I thank you all so
much for watching today's live preview
episode I'm sorry I'm a little
tongue-tied today but I was up very
early prepping things for this week's
after
and you're gonna want to tune in to our
Sweetwater secrets after-show because
basically I have an exclusive interview
with Lilly Reinhardt talking about
something massive that happens in
tonight's episode and I have another
chat with another Riverdale actor that I
can't mention but you'll definitely want
to know what they have to say but for
now please give this video a like and
then follow me on Twitter hit subscribe
all that jazz and then race on down to
the comments to tell me what you think
of The Gargoyle King who you think is
hiding under those little twigs and what
are your thoughts on veggie vs. Varkey
tell me guys and I'll see you soon river
babes bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh God